This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。“百分之二”。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中坚韧精神、体能以及建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。也就是数字 2，在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at It》播客节目中。从 1979 年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84 年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听 Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着你拥有这种能力。并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023 年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》，这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的重大生活改变和转折点及其意义的播客。
for our psychology. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
对我们的心理而言。2%。这就是当有扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧的科学，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness in mind. history. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the
体能，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代社会中建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康理念的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。历史。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。许多
problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode
我们在世界上感到恐慌的问题其实都是压力造成的。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即 I-Heart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-Percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上拍了两次小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·恩格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。包括最近的一集
with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me. just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。坦白说，84 年对我很重要。仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊关于快克的事，但为了让你们知道我的意思。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在台面上了。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 Look Back at It。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求
of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough, Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于胜利与失败的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？还是你当好人只是因为害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway. hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hardway。hard way，立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她证词中明显的自相矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试。我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌诈骗罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你
get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thank you for joining us for another episode. Today, we're going to talk about the idea of Platonic Soulmates. Now, this topic, this idea, was inspired by a conversation that I had with a friend recently.
获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。感谢你加入我们的另一期节目。今天，我们将讨论柏拉图式灵魂伴侣的概念。现在，这个话题，这个想法，是由我最近与一位朋友的对话所启发。
We were talking about relationships, but I think I'm at this stage where the primary relationships in my life are my friendships. And especially in the last two years, I have felt a love and these feelings and emotions for them that are deeper than some of the romantic experiences and romantic connections that I felt. I've had friends, and I've realized this recently, who I have loved more than any boyfriend, than any partner. Their love has sustained me for longer periods of time. It has been unconditional. I can look at them and know that they will never judge me, that they make my life better, that I grow and I learn from them. And it's this feeling that doesn't really seem to fit in the friendship box for me. It's something a lot more profound.
我们当时在谈论人际关系，但我想我正处于这样的人生阶段：我生活中最主要的联系是我的友谊。特别是在过去的两年里，我对他们感受到了一种爱，以及这些深厚的情感，这种情感比我感受过的一些浪漫经历和浪漫连接还要深。我有一些朋友，我最近才意识到这一点，我爱他们胜过任何男朋友，胜过任何伴侣。他们的爱支撑了我更长的时间。那是无条件的。我看着他们，就知道他们永远不会评判我，他们让我的生活变得更好，我在他们身上成长和学习。这种感觉对我来说似乎并不适合放在友谊的盒子里。这是一种深刻得多的东西。
And a key characteristic of those kinds of relationships are that distance doesn't really matter. Proximity doesn't matter. Even similarity doesn't matter. It seems that there is this almost soulful, deep, inexplicable sensation and bond that ties us together. I think we often think about the idea of soulmates and the concept of soulmates in a very restricted, manner. We often think about it in terms of romance. We think about it in terms of sex. And sometimes, and often there is this debate around whether platonic soulmates can even exist. And part of that discussion is whether men and women can really truly be friends and whether friendship between opposite genders
这类关系的一个关键特征是，距离其实并不重要。空间距离不重要。甚至相似性也不重要。似乎存在着一种几乎是心灵深处的、深厚的、无法解释的感觉和纽带将我们联系在一起。我认为我们经常以非常狭隘的方式思考灵魂伴侣的想法和概念。我们通常从浪漫的角度来思考它。我们从性的角度来思考它。有时，而且经常会有一场辩论，围绕着柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣是否真的存在。而这场讨论的一部分是，男人和女人是否真的能成为真正的朋友，以及异性之间的友谊是否
isn't going to be taken up by some sexual tension. And I think that the existence of platonic soulmates is the greatest evidence that. that that can be the case, that that can be the truth. Because these kinds of relationships, they kind of blur the lines between friendship and romance. And I think that's why they're so valuable to talk about today. Sex is not everything. I think we know that. And it's particularly evident when we explore this concept.
不会被某种性张力所占据。我认为柏拉图式灵魂伴侣的存在就是最大的证据。这可以成为现实，这可以成为真相。因为这类关系在一定程度上模糊了友谊和浪漫的界限。我想这就是为什么今天讨论它们如此有价值。性并不是一切。我想我们都知道这一点。当我们探索这个概念时，这一点尤其明显。
So today we're going to explore the psychology behind platonic soulmates, the distinction between these relationships and friendships compared to our partners, whether they are real, what the science and the psychology has to say about the feelings they give us, and the foundation of these deep, almost out-of-body relationships. But further to that, how we know if someone is a platonic soulmate, if someone who has entered our lives matches this profile and this description. This episode, it is dedicated to my Platonic Soulmates, The Loves of My Life. Without further ado, let's get into it.
所以今天我们将探讨柏拉图式灵魂伴侣背后的心理学，这些关系与友谊和我们的伴侣之间的区别，它们是否真实存在，科学和心理学对它们给我们带来的感受有何见解，以及这些深厚的、几乎脱离肉体的关系的基石。不仅如此，我们还将探讨如何知道某人是否是柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣，如何判断一个进入我们生活的人是否符合这个侧写和描述。这一集，献给我的柏拉图式灵魂伴侣们，我生命中的挚爱。闲话少说，让我们切入正题。
A Platonic Soulmate is a feeling of deep connection and understanding without the romance that we typically associate with the term soulmate, without the physical connection, without the sexual chemistry. Consequently, I think that Platonic Soulmates offer each other. almost a deep soul connection that goes beyond feelings of friendship and hits at something deeper that we can't always explain. The term platonic soulmate was named after the famous ancient philosopher Plato who came up or was the first one to express this idea of a relationship and a deep love that cannot be pigeoned hold into a romantic kind of box.
柏拉图式灵魂伴侣是一种深层连接和理解的感觉，但没有我们通常与灵魂伴侣这个词联系在一起的浪漫，没有身体上的连接，没有性的化学反应。因此，我认为柏拉图式灵魂伴侣为彼此提供了一种超越友谊感觉的深度灵魂连接，触及了我们无法总是解释的更深层次的东西。柏拉图式灵魂伴侣这个词以古希腊著名哲学家柏拉图的名字命名，他提出了或最先表达了这种关系和深沉的爱的想法，这种爱不能被归入浪漫的某种特定框架中。
And it breaks away from typical conventions of what we think love should look like. According to this clinical psychologist, her name is Meredith Fuller's. Platonic soulmates are a very long term, solid, trusting and highly satisfying relationship. And this is backed up by this idea of the triangular theory of love that we have spoken about before on the show. So according to the triangular theory of love, there are three things that people want in a relationship. One is passion, and that comes to include things like sex and lust and chemistry and physical
它打破了我们对爱应该是什么样子的典型传统的束缚。根据这位临床心理学家梅雷迪思·富勒（Meredith Fuller）的说法。柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣是一种非常长期的、稳固的、充满信任且高度满足的关系。这得到了我们之前在节目中讨论过的爱情三元论的支持。根据爱情三元论，人们在恋爱关系中想要三样东西。一是激情，包括性、欲望、化学反应和身体
connection. The second is intimacy, and that doesn't just need to mean physical intimacy. It also means emotional intimacy. spiritual intimacy, mental intimacy, and finally, commitment. Those three elements are what makes up any healthy relationship when we think about romance. But we can adapt that triangular theory of love to represent our soulmates and our platonic soulmates in a better life. So it is just those second two characteristics. Firstly, intimacy and secondly, commitment that a platonic soulmate
连接。二是亲密感，这不仅指身体上的亲密。它还意味着情感上的亲密。精神上的亲密，心理上的亲密，最后是承诺。当我们考虑浪漫时，这三个元素构成了任何健康的关系。但我们可以调整爱情三元论，以更好地代表我们的灵魂伴侣和柏拉图式灵魂伴侣。因此，它仅仅包含后两种特征。首先是亲密感，其次是承诺，这是柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣
offers us. And it can also sometimes include passion, not so much sex and lust, hence the term platonic, meaning devoid of sex and devoid of that kind of physical engagement. But passion in another sense, passion for what they're passionate about, passion for their life, passion for their journey. I think it's important to stress, and I know I just said it, but they do not contain this kind of element of lust or sexual arousal, which I think honestly makes out platonics of, and our platonic friendships a lot more sustainable, although that may be controversial. I think when we add sex and we add physical intimacy into the mix, it does become a lot more complicated, which is why we kind of put platonic salmates on a bit of a pedestal.
带给我们的。有时它也可以包括激情，但不是那么多的性和欲望，因此被称为“柏拉图式的”，意味着没有性和那种身体上的接触。但在另一种意义上的激情，对他们所热爱的事物的激情，对他们的生活的激情，对他们的旅程的激情。我认为强调这一点很重要，我知道我刚才说过，但它们不包含这种欲望或性唤起的元素，老实说，我认为这使得柏拉图式的友谊更加持久，尽管这可能会有争议。我认为当我们把性和身体上的亲密感加入其中时，事情确实会变得更加复杂，这就是为什么我们把柏拉图式的伴侣放在一个有点高的神坛上。
They feel more pure to us. And I honestly think that these relationships don't get the credit that they deserve and they're not recognized enough in broader society. We tend to think that there is one person out there for us who is going to make our life a fairy tale. They're going to complete the puzzle, as they say, and that person is the person that we marry or the people that we date, whereas our friendships are kind of secondary to that. And I think the idea and the introduction of this concept of platonic soulmates kind of flips that narrative. But it can be controversial, I think perhaps because of the conflation and use of the term soulmate,
它们让我们觉得更纯粹。老实说，我认为这些关系没有得到它们应有的认可，在更广泛的社会中也没有得到足够的承认。我们往往认为外面有一个人会让我们的人生变成童话。正如他们所说，他们会拼好最后一块拼图，而那个人就是我们结婚或约会的人，而我们的友谊在这个意义上是次要的。我认为柏拉图式灵魂伴侣这个概念的提出和引入颠覆了这种叙事。但这可能会引起争议，我想也许是因为对“灵魂伴侣”这个词的混淆和使用，
which people appear to be really protective over the term soulmates or twin flames. Maybe it's important to stop and kind of rest on that point for a second here. I did do a full episode on it, but essentially it's this idea that you have a connection with someone that extends beyond all reason. It's almost extraterrestrial. It's out of body. It is to do with things like fate and the universe and God. All of these things that we can't always put a tangible name to. And it's this idea that two souls abound in some supernatural way.
人们似乎对“灵魂伴侣”或“双生火焰”这个词有着强烈的保护欲。也许停下来在这个观点上停留一会儿是很重要的。我确实做过一整集关于它的节目，但本质上，这个想法是，你与某人有着一种超越所有理性的联系。它几乎是超地表的存在。它是脱离肉体的。它与命运、宇宙和上帝等事物有关。所有这些我们无法总是给出一个具体名称的事物。这就是两个灵魂以某种超自然的方式结合在一起的想法。
And like I said before, it's often viewed that a partner is what offers you that. There can be this expectation that we marry our soulmates. And we make a life with them. have a family, hence why it's become a massive term in dating. I see this all the time. I get so many DMs about this. I see it on my TikTok algorithm, on my Instagram, about people who want to meet their soulmate or who claim that the person they're marrying is their soulmate. This idea is everywhere, but it's not always applied to our friendships. We have this belief, there is this massive narrative, that we only have one. And I don't believe that is true.
正如我之前所说，人们通常认为伴侣才能为你提供这一点。人们可能会有一种期望，即我们与自己的灵魂伴侣结婚。并与他们共度一生。因此它成为了约会中的一个巨大热词。我经常看到这种情况。我收到了很多关于这方面的私信。我在我的 TikTok 算法上、在我的 Instagram 上看到，关于那些想要遇到他们的灵魂伴侣或者声称他们要结婚的人就是他们的灵魂伴侣的人。这个想法随处可见，但它并不总是适用于我们的友谊。我们有这种信念，有一个巨大的叙事，即我们只有一个。我不相信那是真的。
I think that platonic soulmates do exist. They're not just good friends. They don't have to conflate sex with deep emotional commitment. It's that there is an individual or multiple individuals out there who can provide yourself and your soul with what we normally and typically reserve for only a romantic partner. It's this individual who comes into your life and seems. to have almost this golden touch where they make everything better for you. And it doesn't mean that you need to be sexually attracted to them. I think that that is the point I keep coming back to. But in this situation, I think sex is secondary. And what it shows is that deep emotional commitment
我认为柏拉图式灵魂伴侣确实存在。他们不仅仅是好朋友。他们不必将性与深厚的情感承诺混为一谈。而是有一个或多个人，能够为你和你的灵魂提供我们通常只留给浪漫伴侣的东西。正是这个人走进了你的生活，似乎。几乎拥有这种金手指，能为你让一切变得更好。这并不意味着你需要被他们性吸引。我认为这是我不断回归的观点。但在这种情况下，我认为性是次要的。而它所表明的是，深厚的情感承诺
and sex don't need to coexist for someone to be your soulmate. When I think about this in terms of other examples, I think about people in their 70s who have been together since they were 19 or 20, and they might not be being intimate physically anymore, but a lot of us would look at them and still call them soulmates because there is that emotional commitment. Or I think about asexuality. Just because someone isn't sexually attracted to someone doesn't mean that they can't feel a deep emotional commitment and satisfaction when they're around them. And I think that's what matters the most. It's the emotional intimacy that is shared between two people. Emotional intimacy, I think, matters in every relationship, but when we think about the idea of platonic soulmates, the pressure is a
和性不需要共存，一个人也可以成为你的灵魂伴侣。当我从其他例子来思考这个问题时，我想到了那些七十几岁的人，他们从 19 或 20 岁起就在一起了，他们可能不再有身体上的亲密接触了，但我们中的许多人看着他们，仍然会称他们为灵魂伴侣，因为那里存在着情感承诺。或者我想到了无性恋。仅仅因为某人对某人没有性吸引力，并不意味着当他们在他们身边时，他们就不能感受到深厚的情感承诺和满足感。而我认为这才是最重要的。这是两个人之间分享的情感亲密感。我认为，情感亲密感在每段关系中都很重要，但当我们考虑柏拉图式灵魂伴侣的想法时，与某人建立那种非常自然的情感亲密感的压力会
little bit heightened to have that very organic emotional intimacy with someone. And essentially, this term, this idea, it refers to the sharing of thoughts and feelings with another person in a way that is trusting, in a way that is safe, and in a way that is vulnerable. It's about being emotionally open and honest with each other. And there are three components to emotional intimacy that don't just matter for platonic soulmates, but for all relationships that we want to cultivate and sustain. These are trust, vulnerability and communication. You can't have emotional intimacy with anyone in your life if those three things are not sustained.
稍微增加了一点。本质上，这个词，这个想法，指的是与另一个人分享想法和感受，这种方式是信任的，安全的，并且是脆弱的。这是关于在情感上对彼此开放和诚实。情感亲密感有三个组成部分，它们不仅对柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣重要，而且对我们想要培养和维持的所有关系都很重要。这些是信任、脆弱性和沟通。如果这三件事没有得到维护，你就无法与你生活中的任何人建立情感亲密感。
The first one being trust. Yes, when we think about that in terms of relationships, normally we think about fidelity and infidelity and being able to trust that your partner is loyal and being able to trust that your partner's in your corner. But when we examine that a little bit deeper, I think trust also just refers to the idea and the sensation that this person will always be in your corner,
第一点是信任。是的，当我们从人际关系的层面来考虑这一点时，通常我们会想到忠诚与背叛，能够相信你的伴侣是忠诚的，能够相信你的伴侣是站在你这边的。但当我们更深入地审视这一点时，我认为信任也仅仅指代这样一种理念和感觉：这个人永远会站在你这边，
that they will never be cruel, they'll never be callous, they aren't going to try and cause you harm. And although that might seem like kind of a low barrier or not really a barrier at all, it's quite a low standard that you trust someone isn't going to try and sabotage you, if that isn't in place, if you can't trust that that person really cares about you and cares about your future and your goals and your welfare, how in the world are you meant to move on to that next stage of emotional intimacy, which is vulnerability?
他们永远不会残忍，永远不会冷酷无情，他们不会试图对你造成伤害。尽管这看起来可能是一个很低的门槛，或者根本算不上门槛，但你相信某人不会试图破坏你，这是一个相当低的标准，如果这个标准没有到位，如果你不能相信这个人真的关心你、关心你的未来、你的目标和你的福利，你怎么可能迈向情感亲密感的下一个阶段，也就是脆弱性呢？
I love the idea of vulnerability. I adore it. And as someone who listens to a lot of Bray Brown, who talks about vulnerability quite a bit, I think it is such an undervalued, characteristic and trait and experience to be shared with other people. Being vulnerable doesn't just mean trauma dumping on whoever walks in the door. It's about wanting to share your truth and having it seen and having it heard and knowing that the other person isn't going to judge you and that they will reciprocate your vulnerability with their own. That is what I think is at the heart of any beautiful long-term relationship, whether that be a romantic soulmate or a platonic soulmate, is this idea that you can be your worst self, your best self with that person. You can be so vulnerable.
我喜欢脆弱性的概念。我崇拜它。作为经常听布琳·布朗（Brené Brown）播客的人，她经常谈论脆弱性，我认为这是与其他人类分享的一种被严重低估的特征、特质和体验。展露脆弱并不意味着向任何进门的人倾倒创伤。它是关于想要分享你的真相，并被看到、被听到，并知道对方不会评判你，并且他们会用自己的脆弱来回应你的脆弱。我认为这才是任何美丽的长久关系的核心所在，无论是浪漫的灵魂伴侣还是柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣，就是这种理念：你可以带着最糟糕的自己、最好的自己与那个人相处。你可以变得非常脆弱。
You can break down in front of them. You can be selfish in front of them. You can say, things you've never said to anyone else and they'll still love you. It's that unconditional compassion and unconditional love and affection that they will always have and that's really hard to come by. I think the only way that some people ever feel that is with their family members and even then sometimes that's not the case. So vulnerability is the second ingredient of emotional intimacy that I think is important to remember and to kind of to cultivate. And the final one is communication. You can't know someone, you can't love someone, you can't see someone if the relationship is only
你可以在他们面前崩溃。你可以在他们面前表现得很自私。你可以说出你从未对任何人说过的话，他们依然会爱你。那是他们永远都会拥有的无条件的同情、无条件的爱与关怀，而这真的很难得。我认为有些人唯一能感受到这一点的方式是通过他们的家人，即便如此，有时情况也并非如此。所以脆弱性是情感亲密感的第二个要素，我认为记住这一点并加以培养是很重要的。最后一个是沟通。如果你不进行开放的沟通，不让别人真正了解你脑海中在想什么，你就无法真正了解一个人、爱一个人或看清一个人。我认为沟通就是窥视我们潜意识和无意识的一种方式，能让别人看到我们希望他们看到的东西。有一种观点，我认为阻碍了我们的许多浪漫关系、甚至有时还有我们的友谊的是，人们认为别人应该能够读懂你的心思，认为如果他们足够了解你，你就不需要与他们沟通你的感受以及你身上发生了什么。但所有良好的关系都有一种沟通水平，
marked by silence, if you don't openly communicate about what is actually going on in your brain. And I think communication is this way of peering into our subconscious and our unconscious minds and allowing someone to see the things that we want them to see. There is this idea and I think the thing that gets in the way of a lot of our romantic relationships and even our friendships sometimes is thinking that people should be able to read your mind and thinking that if they know you well enough, you shouldn't have to communicate with them how you're feeling and what's going on with you. But all good relationships have a level of communication that.
这使它们得以维持。无论你是否与某人通过这种神奇的、深情的、无法解释的纽带联系在一起，你仍然需要能够与他们沟通，向他们展示你关心他们，让他们进入你的大脑。所以这些是情感亲密感的三个支柱，我认为它们使我们能够拥有并提供拥有灵魂伴侣想法的机会。它们再次是：信任、脆弱性和沟通。如果你没有这些，你就无法与其他人建立情感亲密感。我认为这与身体亲密感有很大的不同。我认为这甚至不需要解释。
allows them to be sustained. And regardless of whether you are connected with someone through this magical, soulful, inexplicable bond, you still need to be able to communicate with them and show them that you care and let them into your mind. So those are the three kind of pillars of emotional intimacy that I think allow us and provide us with the opportunity to have an idea like soulmates. they are again trust, vulnerability and communication. And if you don't have those, you won't be able to be emotionally intimate with someone else. And I think that differs from physical intimacy a lot. I don't even think that needs explaining.
但有时我们使用身体亲密感来掩饰我们的脆弱，并以此避免与某人在情感上保持亲密。因此，这就产生了“情感不可及”的概念，当我们把关系仅仅看作化学反应和火花时，我们忘记了最重要的事情，那就是那种深刻的连接感、与某人共处并允许他们进入的能力。我想这就是我们看到柏拉图式灵魂伴侣的概念真正发挥作用的地方，因为在这种情况下，没有那种性的元素，没有那种身体上的亲密感。这段关系完全建立在情感亲密感的基础上，
But sometimes we use physical intimacy to kind of mask our vulnerability and to kind of prevent us from having to be emotionally intimate with someone. hence the idea of emotional unavailability, when we see a relationship only as chemistry and only as that spark, we forget about the thing that matters the most, which is that deep connection and ability to be present with someone and to let them in. And I think that's where we see the idea of platonic soulmates really come into play, because in that situation, there isn't that sexual element, there isn't that physical intimacy. The relationship, is built on purely a foundation of emotional intimacy,
同时也建立在心理和精神上的亲密感之上。我想花点时间谈谈我自己的柏拉图式灵魂伴侣。有一段时间，我想我并不真的相信你可以拥有一个不是你浪漫依恋或吸引对象的灵魂伴侣。我们太执着于我刚才说的那个非常狭隘的叙事，即灵魂伴侣是你结婚的人，他们是你建立家庭的人，他们是你一生的挚爱。然后突然间我进入了人生的这个阶段，我的二十岁，在这个阶段，整个光谱，
and then also mental and spiritual intimacy as well. I kind of want to take a moment to talk about my own platonic soulmates. For a while, I think I didn't really believe in this idea that you could have a soulmate that wasn't someone you were romantically attached to or attracted to. We're so, like I said, this very narrow narrative that soulmates are the people that you marry, They're the people that you build a family with. They're the loves of your life. And then suddenly I entered this era of my life, of my 20s, in which that entire spectrum,
浪漫的整个领域和范畴，我的浪漫生活基本上有点关闭了。当我允许我生活中的那个领域逐渐消亡，基本上被置于次要地位时，所有这些关系，所有这些关系和所有这些友谊开始绽放，开出我从未想象过的友谊之花。我想到了一个了不起的人的例子，她的名字叫格蕾丝（Gracie），我去年遇到了她，她几乎立刻就进入了我的生活。那是一种我从未体验过的感觉。当涉及到约会时，我从未体验过。在任何领域，我都真的从未体验过。就像是一种即时的认同，在某种程度上我们是同一个人，
that entire era and field of romance, my romantic life basically kind of shut off. And when I allowed that area of my life to kind of fizzle and to take kind of be put on the back burner essentially, all of these relationships and all of these relationships and all of these friendships started blossoming and blooming into friendships that I never could have imagined. And I think about this one example of this amazing person, her name was Gracie, that I met last year, and almost instantly she entered my life. And it was a feeling that I have never experienced. I've never experienced it when it comes to dating. I've never experienced it really in any domain. it was like this instant recognition that in some way we were the same person
在某种程度上我知道她将永远留在我的生活中。这是如此令人震撼，但我记得对她说这样的话，并觉得，我觉得我们会成为最好的朋友。我认为我们对彼此会非常棒。当我这么说的时候，我能想到的只有那些和某人约会并在婚礼上讲述他们是如何告诉对方他们要娶他们的例子的那些人。这真的感觉有点像那样。感觉就像是，哇，我是不是刚刚遇到了我一生的挚爱？
and in some way I knew that she would be in my life forever. And it was so confronting, but I remember like saying that to her and being like, I think we're going to be best friends. I think that we are going to be amazing for each other. And when I said that, all I can think about was those examples of people who go on a date with someone and recount at their wedding how they told them they were going to marry them. Like it really did kind of feel like that. It felt like, wow, have I just met like the love of my life?
在某些方面，我想我确实遇到了。我想，当我允许我的大脑把我和人们的深厚关系看作不仅仅是浪漫连接时，当我不再把我的所有关系都死板地归类为要么是浪漫的要么仅仅是友谊时，一种全新的亲密感和脆弱性对我敞开了。这简直是最奇妙的体验，并为我带来了如此多的快乐。尤其是在我们二十岁的时候，当我们真正渴望连接时，偶遇一个柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣感觉就像，感觉改变了人生。
And in some ways, I think that I had. I think when I allowed my brain to see my relationships and the deep relationships I had with people as more than just romantic connections and I stopped pigeonholing all of my relationships into kind of like either these are romantic or they're just friendships, this whole new level of intimacy and vulnerability opened up for me. and it was just the most amazing experience and has provided me with so much joy. And especially in our 20s when we really are reaching for connection, stumbling across a platonic soulmate just feels like, it feels life-changing.
所以接下来我想谈谈究竟是什么造就了柏拉图式灵魂伴侣，以及我们如何能够知道并识别我们遇到的人是否可能是这些人之一。所有这些以及更多内容，稍后揭晓。我觉得我花这集的前半部分，真的只是在长篇大论地谈论柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣有多么惊人，为什么浪漫和性并不是全部。我想你大概能听出来我对这个话题充满热情。但这其实并没有给我们或你们提供太多关于这到底意味着什么的具体信息。对某人来说，成为所谓的柏拉图式灵魂伴侣到底意味着什么。首先，我认为将他们与浪漫的灵魂伴侣以及我们对浪漫灵魂伴侣的概念区分开来的事情是，你可以拥有不止一个。正如我之前所说，我们通常习惯通过非常狭隘的视角来看待灵魂伴侣，那就是他们是浪漫的伴侣，我们有一个，并且我们找到了他们。但实际上，你可以拥有不止一个灵魂伴侣。灵魂伴侣是你选择投入其中的人，是一个你与之有深厚连接的个人，这个星球上有这么多人，你注定会与不止一个人产生这种感觉。我这么说并不是出于一种愤世嫉俗的态度，说什么“灵魂伴侣的想法根本不存在”，而是我认为我不喜欢单数的灵魂伴侣这个概念。我喜欢复数的灵魂伴侣这个概念。这本质上就是为什么我认为柏拉图式灵魂伴侣如此、如此迷人且非常值得讨论的原因，因为它确实有力地反驳了这样一种叙事：世界上只有一个人是为你准备的，他们会让你圆满，他们会让你成为最快乐的自己，而其他所有人与之相比都是次要的。我也认为它们重新定义了友谊的典型理念和典型结构。心理学中我们所知的典型友谊基于三种条件，它们在三种条件存在的情况下形成，即邻近性、相似性和互惠性。所以本质上，为了建立一段友谊，你需要与那个人保持亲近。距离不能真的是个问题，因为你需要有便利性，嗯，我猜只是能够偶然遇到他们并随时组织计划并真正在日常生活中见到他们的便利性。第二是相似性。我认为这归结为价值观。培养一段与你毫无共同点的友谊是非常困难的，虽非不可能，但我要说非常困难。所有的友谊都需要这种相似性的基石。也许这种相似性关于你们俩上的同一所大学，或者你们拥有的一些爱好或激情，或者是价值观方面的相似性。这并不重要，但通常情况下，如果没有某种将你们联系在一起的东西和共同的兴趣，友谊就无法形成。典型友谊的最后一个条件是互惠性。所以本质上这意味着你们回报彼此的意图，并且你们回报彼此的能量。
So what I want to talk about next is what actually makes a platonic soulmate and how we can know and how we can identify if someone we've met might just be one of these people. So all of that and more in just a second. I feel like I spent the first half of this episode really just going on a bit of a rant about how amazing platonic soulmates are and why romance and sex is and everything. And I guess you could probably hear that I'm very passionate about this. But it didn't really give us or you guys much information about what exactly that means. What does it actually mean for someone to. be a quote-unquote platonic soulmate. Firstly, I think the thing that distinguishes them from a romantic
因此，我们需要满足这三个条件来建立任何友谊。但随着友谊加深，随着你可能开始意识到你与之交朋友这个人可能不仅仅是个朋友，他们可能是柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣，其中一些条件实际上变得不那么重要了。我们必须提醒自己，柏拉图式灵魂伴侣的想法仍然建立在那种深厚的、充满灵魂的、命中注定的纽带的假设之上。而这些纽带不会随着距离而消失。它们不会随着相似性而消失。
soulmate and our concept of a romantic soulmate is that you can have more than one. Like I said before, there is this very narrow lens that we were typically used to viewing soulmates through and that is that they are these romantic partners and we have one and we found them. But really, you can have more than one soulmate. A soulmate is someone that you choose to invest in and it's an individual who you feel a deep connection with and there are so many people on this planet, you are bound to feel that with more than one person. And I'm not saying that in a cynical way of, you know, the idea of soulmates doesn't even exist, but I think that I don't like the idea of a soulmate singular. I like the idea of a soulmate plural. And that's essentially why I think platonic soulmates are so, so
在某些情况下，即使你们不再出现在彼此的生活中，也不再回报所投入的努力，它们也不会消失。灵魂伴侣的存在与否，并不取决于你们是否保持常年联系或一周七天二十四小时黏在一起，因为这几乎就像是你们都在汲取并以某种方式共享的双重能量源。这种想法是，这种纽带永远不会褪色，因为它是命中注定的。
fascinating and so worthwhile to discuss because it really pushes back against this narrative that there is one person out there for you, they will fulfill you, they will make you the happiest version of yourself and everyone else is kind of secondary to that. I also think they define the typical idea and the typical structure of a friendship. Typical friendships as we know in psychology are based off of three kind of conditions and they're formed in the presence of three conditions and those are proximity, similarity and reciprocity. So essentially for a friendship to form, you need to be close to that person. Distance can't really be a problem because you need to have the convenience and, well, I guess just the convenience of being able to run into them and readily organize
而对于柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣，我认为施加在他们身上的压力要小得多。当我们考虑我们的浪漫关系和浪漫的灵魂伴侣时，有很多关于需要生孩子和需要结婚的言论。然后，当我们成为伴侣时，这些经济责任就会落到我们头上。随着年龄的增长，我们必须分担财务并做出妥协。而在柏拉图式的关系和柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣中，我认为这不那么是一个优先事项。你能够更好地让另一个人做他们自己，而没有被浪漫缠绕的压力。我想这就是我们真正看到关系和浪漫灵魂伴侣之间区别的地方。
plans and actually see them in your daily life. The second is similarity. I think this comes down to values. it is very hard, not impossible, but very hard, I would say, to cultivate a friendship with someone that you have nothing in common with. All friendships need this bedrock of similarity. And maybe that similarity in regards to the university that you both attend or some hobby or passion that you have or a similarity in terms of values. It doesn't really matter, but typically a friendship cannot form if there isn't something kind of linking you together and some joint interest. And the final condition for a typical friendship is reciprocity. So essentially what that means is that you reciprocate each other's intentions and you reciprocate each other's energy.
柏拉图式灵魂伴侣和普通朋友。没有那么大的压力总是黏在彼此身边并承担所有这些共同的责任，但这也是一种友谊，比一般的点头之交或普通友谊更深厚，具有更持久的纽带。这两种理念的交汇点就是我们找到柏拉图式灵魂伴侣的地方。那么，你如何知道你生活中的某个人是否是柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣呢？我认为这本身就是一个问题和一个答案，
So we do need those three conditions to be met to make any friendship. But as a friendship gains its deepness, as you might come to realize that this person you're friends with may be more than just a friend, they may be a platonic soulmate, some of those conditions actually become less important. We've got to remind ourselves, the idea of a platonic soulmate still rests on that assumption of this deep, soulful, fate-like bond. And those bonds do not disappear with distance. they do not disappear with similarity.
因为如果你必须问自己这个问题，他们大概就不是。我知道这真的很残酷，但灵魂伴侣的理念在于你的灵魂和他们的灵魂互相认出了对方。我知道这并没有太多的心理学依据，而且对于我们为什么会这样认为，可能有一个非常非常复杂的生物学和心理学解释。但如果我们只是从这种一般原型和叙事的角度来谈论，这就是一个灵魂认出另一个灵魂的想法。所以如果你必须回过头来真正质疑这一点，并且你必须质疑他们是否是你的柏拉图式灵魂伴侣，那么他们大概率不是。
And in some cases, they do not disappear, even if you guys are no longer in each other's lives and reciprocating the effort that is put in. A soulmate is going to exist regardless of whether you guys are in constant contact or around each other 24-7, because it's almost like this dual energy source that you're both tapping into and you both share in some ways. The idea is that this bond never fades because it was predestined.
在某些情况下，它们不会消失，即使你们不再参与彼此的生活，也不再回应所付出的努力。无论你们是否保持经常联系或24小时呆在彼此身边，灵魂伴侣都将存在，因为这几乎就像你们都在汲取并在某种程度上共享的双重能量源。这种纽带永远不会消退，因为它是命中注定的。
And with platonic soulmates, I think there's a lot less pressure that's placed on them. When we think about our romantic relationships and our romantic soulmates, there is a lot of rhetoric around the need to have children and the need to get married. And then we have these financial responsibilities that kind of fall into our lap when we become a couple. and as we get older, we've got to share finances and make compromises. And in platonic relationships and platonic soulmates, I think that's less of a priority. You are more able to allow the other person to just be who they want to be without the pressure of being romantically intertwined. And I think that's where we really see the distinction between a relationship and a romantic soulmate.
至于柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣，我认为强加给它们的压力要小得多。当我们考虑浪漫关系和浪漫的灵魂伴侣时，有很多关于需要生孩子和需要结婚的言论。然后，当我们成为情侣时，这些财务责任就会落到我们头上，随着年龄的增长，我们需要分担财务并做出妥协。而在柏拉图式的关系和柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣中，我认为这不那么重要。你更能让对方做他们想做自己，而没有纠缠于浪漫关系的压力。我认为这就是我们真正看到关系与浪漫灵魂伴侣之间区别的地方。
a platonic soulmate and then just a friendship. There is not as much pressure to be in each other's pockets all the time and to have all those shared responsibilities, but it's also a friendship that is deeper and has a more lasting bond than a typical acquaintance or a typical friendship. That intersection of those two ideas is where we find our platonic soulmate. So how do you know if someone in your life is a platonic soulmate? I think that's actually kind of a question and an answer in itself,
柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣，然后只是一种友谊。没有那么大的压力非要时刻黏在一起并承担所有这些共同的责任，但这也是一种比典型熟人或典型友谊更深厚、纽带更持久的友谊。这两种想法的交汇点就是我们找到柏拉图式灵魂伴侣的地方。那么，你怎么知道你生命中的某个人是否是柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣呢？我认为这本身就是一个问题和一个答案，
because if you have to ask yourself that question, they're probably not. And I know that's really harsh, but the idea of a soulmate is that your soul and their soul recognize each other. And I know that's not based in a lot of psychology, and there is probably a very, very intricate biological, psychological explanation as to why we think that's the case. but if we're just talking in terms of this kind of general archetype in this narrative, it is this idea that your soul recognises another soul. So if you have to double back and really question that, and you have to question whether they're your platonic soulmate, the chances are that they're not.
因为如果你必须问自己这个问题，他们可能就不是。我知道这很残酷，但灵魂伴侣的概念是你的灵魂和他们的灵魂认出了彼此。我知道这没有什么心理学基础，而且对于为什么我们认为情况如此，可能有一个非常非常复杂的生物学、心理学解释，但如果我们只是从这种普遍的原型和叙事来谈论，这就是你的灵魂认出另一个灵魂的概念。所以如果你必须回过头来真正质疑这一点，并且你必须质疑他们是否是你的柏拉图式灵魂伴侣，那么他们大概率不是。
But there are some other signs that are really strong and important to remember. So there is that instant recognition. It's almost like family, almost like you've known them, in a past life. And once again, that is not a psychological term. In psychology, the idea of a past life is not one that is seen as valid or reliable, but you can believe in what you want to believe. And it's this idea that we have past selves, we've lived lives before. And in those lives, someone that you were close to or someone that was important to you has returned in the form or the body of a soulmate in this life. So that's kind of more of a spiritually enlightened idea
但还有一些其他非常强烈且重要的迹象需要记住。那就是瞬间的认同感。这几乎就像家人一样，仿佛你们在前世就认识。再说一次，这不是一个心理学词汇。在心理学中，前世的概念并不被视为有效或可靠的，但你可以相信你想相信的东西。这种观点认为我们有前世的自我，我们以前活过。在那些生活中，你曾经亲近的人或对你重要的人，在这一生中以灵魂伴侣的形式或身体回来了。所以这更像是一种精神上受到启迪的观点
of this recognition. But I think that instant recognition that we feel can also be explained by some science as well. Similarity is incredibly powerful. If you share the same values as someone, if you share the same interest as someone, if you share the same neighborhood as someone and the same friends as them as well, it makes it a lot easier for you to get along. And so when you initially meet someone and you're doing all those, that kind of initial snooping work and seeing where they stand and seeing what they're all about, often in those instances, the part of our brain that is searching for similar connections is going to see their similarity to us as a real positive.
对这种认同感的理解。但我认为，我们感受到的这种瞬间认同感也可以用一些科学来解释。相似性具有不可思议的力量。如果你和某人有相同的价值观，如果你和某人有相同的兴趣，如果你和某人住在同一个社区，还有相同的朋友，这会让你更容易相处。因此，当你最初遇到某人并做所有这些初步的探索工作，看看他们的立场，看看他们是怎么样的人时，通常在这些情况下，我们大脑中寻找相似联系的部分会将他们与我们的相似之处视为一个真正的积极因素。
trait and therefore attach ourselves to them at a greater rate and kind of magnify how much we like them. So that's kind of more of a psychological explanation for that recognition. And the recognition is perhaps the biggest indicator of a platonic soulmate. The next is one that I mentioned before, but you should be able to be your best self, but also your worst self with that person. I was having this discussion with a friend the other day actually and it's this person that I have known since I was like maybe 10 or 11 years old. She is my best friend. She is a platonic soulmate. I don't even want to use the term platonic. She is just a soulmate. And I was saying to her, isn't it just so beautiful that no matter what we do in life, you could do the worst thing a person could ever do
因此，我们会以更高的频率依附于他们，并放大我们对他们的喜爱程度。所以这更像是对这种认同感的心理学解释。而这种认同感也许是柏拉图式灵魂伴侣最大的指标。接下来是我之前提到的一点，但你应该能够在那个人面前展现最好的自己，也能展现最糟糕的自己。其实前几天我和一个朋友在讨论这个，这个人我从大概10岁或11岁起就认识了。她是我最好的朋友。她是一个柏拉图式的灵魂伴侣。我甚至不想用“柏拉图式”这个词。她就是我的灵魂伴侣。当时我对她说，难道不是很美好吗？无论我们在生活中做什么，你做了别人可能做过的最糟糕的事
and I could still love you. I might not forgive you. I might not agree with what you've done, but I would still love you and I would still support you. And that is just the most powerful feeling for someone to say to you, I think, the most powerful thing for someone to say to you, to say regardless of your worst self, I will still love you. And I think it also comes with the idea that if you're saying that to someone,
而我依然可以爱你。我可能不会原谅你。我可能不同意你所做的事，但我也依然会爱着你，我依然会支持你。我认为，这是对某人说出的最具力量的感觉，对某人说出的最具力量的话，无论你最糟糕的自我如何，我依然会爱你。我认为这同时也伴随着这样一种想法：如果你对某人这样说，
you probably know what their worst self. is already and you're willing to accept that. So it's not like they're going to turn it into like a mass murderer. You probably wouldn't say that to someone who you're convinced is actually inherently a bad person. But regardless of that, I do still think that is a really massive component of the deepness of this connection is your willingness to accept them when they are on their best behavior, when they're on their worst behavior, when they are the best version of themselves or the worst version of themselves. It's all a package deal, right? And you're willing to accept that. The next indicator, I think, is that it's easy. The best relationships in life are
你可能已经知道他们最糟糕的一面是什么了，并且你愿意接受这一点。所以这并不是说他们会变成一个杀人狂。你可能不会对一个你确信本质上是个坏人的人说这样的话。但尽管如此，我仍然认为这是这种深刻联系中一个非常巨大的组成部分，那就是你愿意接受他们在表现最好时的样子、表现最糟糕时的样子，当他们是最好的自己或最糟糕的自己时。这一切都是一个整体，对吧？而你愿意接受这一点。我认为，下一个指标就是一切都很轻松。生活中最好的关系是
easy. They don't require you to push yourself to a point of being uncomfortable. They don't leave you questioning, oh, what are we going to talk about when we see each other next? There is none of that friction. And I think that that friction is really noticeable in some relationships. And in a platonic soulmate situation, it's probably, there is none. There shouldn't be any friction. It should just feel like you're flowing down a very easygoing river and this person is by your side. I think there is also this mutual understanding of the other person's needs, obviously not without communication and you still need to communicate those, but it's this awareness of what they need in their life. It's this awareness of, I guess, their love languages and their insecurities and maybe some of their childhood
轻松的。它们不需要你把自己推到一个感到不舒服的地步。它们不会让你质疑，哦，我们下次见面时要聊什么？没有那种摩擦。我认为这种摩擦在某些关系中非常明显。而在柏拉图式灵魂伴侣的情况下，可能完全没有。不应该有任何摩擦。它应该就像你顺着一条非常轻松的河流漂流，而这个人就在你身边。我认为，这其中也包含对对方需求的相互理解，当然这离不开沟通，你仍然需要把这些需求表达出来，但这就是对他们在生活中需要什么的一种意识。我想，这也是对他们的爱语、他们的不安全感以及他们的一些童年
wounds. All of that is something that the other person has taken time to understand and still loves about you, but is also willing to address with you, with you by their side. And then there are some other ones that I think are just added bonuses, right? And are definitely indicators of this type of relationship. Laughter. Laughter is the most amazing thing. And I think it's because when we're enjoying someone's company and where we feel free to laugh and to be entertained by them, we are saying to them, I am so totally comfortable with you. And I'm not laughing because I'm nervous. I'm not laughing because this is the natural response to you telling a bad joke. It's because I genuinely find you funny and because I genuinely love being around you. And it's kind of like those situations.
创伤的一种意识。所有这些都是对方花时间去理解并依然爱你的部分，但他也愿意与你一起面对，有你陪伴在他身边。然后还有一些其他的，我认为只是额外的奖励，对吧？绝对是这种关系的指标。笑声。笑声是最神奇的东西。我认为这是因为，当我们享受某人的陪伴，并且觉得可以自由地笑、被他们逗乐时，我们是在对他们说：和你在一起我感到完全的放松。我笑不是因为我紧张。我笑也不是因为对你讲的一个烂笑话做出的自然反应。而是因为我真的觉得你很搞笑，因为我真的喜欢和你在一起。这就有点像那种情况。
I don't know if you've ever had those where you're with a friend and like me and my friends call it the sillies. Like everything they do is just hilarious because you feel so comfortable that all of that joy and happiness kind of bubbles to the surface. It's not that they're, you know, the next Jerry Seinfeld or the next Amy Polar. They don't have to be like the most hilarious person technically, but it's because they allow your joy to bubble over. And I think that is just the most beautiful thing. They also allow you to sit in silence. You can sit in silence with this person and it not be awkward. It all comes back to that sense of being comfortable in their presence because some part of you recognises some part of them and you both know it's the same. You recognize you.
我不知道你有没有过这样的经历，你和朋友在一起，我和我的朋友们称之为“傻气时刻”。就像他们做的每一件事都极其搞笑，因为你感到如此舒适，以至于所有的喜悦和快乐都涌上了表面。并不是说他们是下一个杰瑞·宋飞（Jerry Seinfeld）或下一个艾米·波勒（Amy Poehler）。从技术上讲，他们不需要是最搞笑的人，而是因为他们让你的快乐溢出来了。我认为这简直是最美好的事情。他们还让你能够安于沉默。你可以和这个人相对无言，而不会感到尴尬。这一切都回归到在他们面前感到舒适的那种感觉，因为你内心的某一部分认出了他们内心的某一部分，而且你们都知道是一样的。你认出了你自己
a part of yourself in that other person. And they help you grow. They help you become a better version of yourself because they know you well enough to know what's going to motivate you. They know you well enough to know what are you insecure about, but what also your ambitions and I'm so invested in your life, you're so invested in mine that I want to be able to bring you to that level where you want to be. So I guess that's kind of an extensive list. But when I was thinking back to my own experiences with this idea of a platonic soulmate, those were the things that really came to mind for me and they were the ones that really stood out to me as distinguishing perhaps just a regular friendship or a regular acquaintance and this kind of deeper, inexplicable connection
在这另一个人身上的一部分。他们帮你成长。他们帮你成为更好的自己，因为他们足够了解你，知道什么能激励你。他们足够了解你，知道你的不安全感是什么，但同时也知道你的雄心壮志是什么，我对你的生活投入了那么多，你也对我的生活投入了那么多，以至于我想把你带到你想去的高度。所以我想这是一个很长的列表。但当我回想起自己对柏拉图式灵魂伴侣这个概念的亲身经历时，这些确实是我脑海中最先浮现的事情，也是真正对我而言脱颖而出的事情，它们区分了普通的友谊或泛泛之交与这种更深层次的、无法解释的联系
that we just appear to have with some people. I do want to say here, though, there is a lot of hype around this idea of soulmates, platonic, romantic or otherwise. And sometimes that can leave those of us who don't quite know if we've met these people feeling like a failure, feeling like there's something wrong with us that everyone around us is having these deep, meaningful connections and we're not. I don't think that's the case. I really don't think that's the case. I think I am a big proponent of the argument that soulmates are not just met.
我们似乎只与某些人建立这种联系。不过，我想在这里说的是，围绕灵魂伴侣这个概念（无论是柏拉图式的、浪漫的还是其他的）有很多炒作。有时，这会让我们当中那些不太确定自己是否遇到过这样的人感到自己像个失败者，觉得我们身上出了什么问题，因为周围的每个人都在建立这种深厚、有意义的联系，而我们却没有。我不认为情况是这样的。我真的不认为情况是这样的。我非常赞同这样一种观点：灵魂伴侣不仅仅是被遇见的，
so made. There may be someone in your life who, with the bit of extra effort and energy and the time to build that vulnerability, will be a platonic soulmate, will be your person. But I also like to remind myself at times, and I like to remind others who feel insecure about the fact that maybe their relationships aren't as deep as they would like them to be, that you haven't yet met all the people that you have loved and all the people who will love you. your future is so wide, especially for those of us in our 20s. And you have decades ahead of you to meet the most spectacular, amazing people. And you should wait for them.
而是被塑造成的。你的生命中可能会有这样一个人，只要付出一点额外的努力、精力和时间去建立这种脆弱感，他就会成为你的柏拉图式灵魂伴侣，成为你的命中注定。但我也经常提醒自己，我也想提醒那些对自己关系的深度可能不如预期而感到不安全的人，你还没有遇到所有你爱过的人，也没有遇到所有会爱你的的人。你的未来是如此广阔，特别是对于我们这些二十多岁的人来说。在你面前有几十年的时间去遇到最壮丽、最神奇的人。你应该等待他们。
You shouldn't force it with someone. I promise that these people show up when you least expect them. And I hate that saying, but I guess it's true, which annoys me even more. but they will just show up in your life when you most need them and when you least expect them. And like I said, there will be that instant recognition. No one goes through life unloved, I think. There's not a single person I know in this world. Not a single person who exists who I think goes through life unloved by at least someone around them or even a stranger.
你不应该勉强和某人在一起。我向你保证，这些人总是在你最意想不到的时候出现。我讨厌这种说法，但我想这是真的，这更让我恼火。但他们就会在最需要他们的时候、最意想不到的时候出现在你的生活中。就像我说的，会有那种瞬间的认同感。我认为，没有人的人生是没有被爱过的。在这个世界上，我认识的没有一个人。没有一个存在的人，我认为他的人生是没有周围的某个人甚至是一个陌生人去爱的。
So you don't need to have met your platonic soulmate and have a best friend or the person that is the love of your life right now, that will come. It will come and you can also cultivate that and you can be your own soulmate. Sometimes that's a really beautiful way of seeing things, that anything that you think of friendship or of relationship needs to give you, you can give yourself. And that includes some of that unconditional love we were speaking about, some of that mutual understanding of needs,
所以你不需要现在就遇到你的柏拉图式灵魂伴侣，也不需要现在就拥有最好的朋友或你一生的挚爱，那会来的。它会到来的，你也可以培养它，你可以成为你自己的灵魂伴侣。有时候，这是一种非常美妙的看待事物的方式，你认为友谊或关系需要给予你的一切，你都可以自己给自己。这包括我们刚才谈到的一些无条件地爱，一些对需求的相互理解，
some of that laughter, some of that space to grow, those are all things that you can give to you. And we don't always need to be looking outwardly to have those maids net. So I just want to say that if you're listening to this being like, oh my goodness, what am I doing wrong? This platonic soulmate idea sounds amazing. I want to get in on that and I haven't been able to yet. Don't worry about it.
一些欢笑，一些成长的空间，这些都是你可以给予自己的东西。我们并不总是需要向外寻求来满足这些需求。所以我只想说，如果你在听这个节目时觉得：哦天哪，我到底做错了什么？这个柏拉图式灵魂伴侣的想法听起来太棒了。我想参与其中，但我目前还没能做到。别担心。
There'll be someone out there. There'll be multiple people out there who are going to show up in your life and fill that cup so full, you're going to need more cups. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. If you have a platonic soulmate of your own, you should tell me about them. Or you should share this episode with them. Let them know that they are seen and that you love them and that you will always be there for them. I'm going to send this episode to my platonic soulmate.
总会有人出现在那里的。会有多个人出现在你的生活中，把你的杯子斟得满满的，以至于你需要更多的杯子。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。如果你有自己的柏拉图式灵魂伴侣，你应该跟我讲讲他们。或者你应该把这一集分享给他们。让他们知道他们被看见了，你爱他们，你将永远陪伴他们。我要把这一集发给我的柏拉图式灵魂伴侣。
I'm hoping that she's already listening. But if not, here's her reminder to subscribe to my show. and leave me a five-star review. I'm hoping she's already done that as well. But if you haven't, you should take some time to leave a five-star review wherever you are listening right now. It really helps the show to grow
我希望她已经在收听了。如果没有，这就是她订阅我的节目并给我留下一条五星好评的提醒。我希望她也已经这样做了。但如果你还没这样做，你应该花点时间在你现在收听的任何地方留下一条五星好评。这真的对节目的成长有很大帮助
and to reach new people and new audiences. And it also makes my day. I read every single one of your reviews when I'm feeling good, when I'm feeling bad. They always just make me happier. So if you have an episode suggestion as well, please feel free to follow me at that psychology podcast and send me a DM with your idea. I love hearing about your experiences and how they relate to my own,
并触及新的人群和新的受众。这也让我的一天变得美好。当我感觉良好或感觉糟糕时，我都会阅读你们的每一条评论。它们总是能让我更开心。所以，如果你也有节目建议，请随时在“那个心理学播客”（that psychology podcast）关注我，并给我发私信分享你的想法。我喜欢听你们的经历以及它们如何与我自己的经历相关联，
but also how they may be somewhat universal for a lot of us in our 20s. So follow me over there and send me your episode suggestions, send me your feedback or just say hi. And as always, thank you so much for listening to today's episode. we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
但也想知道它们对于我们许多二十多岁的人来说如何在某种程度上具有普遍性。所以在那里关注我并把你的节目建议发给我，把你的反馈发给我，或者只是打个招呼。像往常一样，非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在我的播客“2%”中。我剖析了精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“2%”。也就是数字TWO percent。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在“回顾过去”（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for Black. Black people. Listen to look back at it on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe
84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。黑人。请在I Heart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”（Look Back at it）。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）主持的“艰难学习”（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方
to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct?
真的都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难的方式（Learn the hard way）。在2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的遭遇。格雷、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是“深陷爱情”（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“深陷爱情”（Love Trapped）播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。